How do we connect
Snowflakes fractals the brain computes what where where's this all-star, so we're gonna. Have a look at fractals
We first of all have to define what the heck is a fractal. That's the first thing we need to do
I'll show you some examples in nature, and then I want to try and connect that to
Pretty recent research that's been going on in terms of what are called neuromorphic structures trying to
Have devices trying to have computing
Architectures which are much more aligned with how our brain computes and the perhaps?
more correctly much more in line with how our brain is wired and
The ability for our brain to make new connections to be plastic to make different connections. There's a whole
burgeoning whole really developing area of research, which is incredibly exciting in terms of trying to take that type of
Process and that type of dynamic and embed it in sort of inorganic systems
We said in the last video
What does a computer do well it takes in information and does something to that information and outputs other?
Information sort of what we do we take in a huge range of sensory inputs
We do something to them which results in some output. We do something we feel something etc
So it's a question about how that information is processed and of course we don't have CMOS up here
We don't have incredibly regimented and well-organized top-down
Sculpted pieces of silicon and do all the processing up here were a mess particularly
I'm particularly a mess, but if you look at the structure of the brain. It's incredibly branched and incredibly dendritic
Lots of different pathways if you look at a nerve cell you look at a neuron very fingery and very branched etcetera
Almost random it looks like certainly not like a very rigid grid like type structure as we have with CMOS so
the question then is you know what's happening in terms of the
Just how the brain processes information and of course you know
you have
incredibly good
incredibly powerful pieces of silicon technology that can you know I perform us in so many ways
But then you ask it to distinguish between a Chihuahua and a blueberry muffin, and it gets completely screwed
So where we went out, so what is it about how we process information?
I'd love to say we're going to address that question
We're not quite
But we're going to certainly look at the role of sort of fractal and dendritic structures so basically what is a fractal?
What is a dendritic structure and why are they important in information processing?
first-year student here in physics of nottingham noah, Hardwicke
Come in give me a Christmas card which was very very nice of him
But what I did not first realize is that this is a computer-generated?
Christmas card all the code is in here and moreover. It's unique there was no other
Christmas card like this you'll have much the same structure another Christmas cards
But it would be very slightly different because all of these features the snowflakes the ferns the trees are
Fractal in nature, and he's generated them with a piece of code and every time it'll be slightly different
So it is truly a unique Christmas card
So it's very happy to get that not least because Sean and I had been planning this video is a very timely
Christmas card to get snowflakes are
Incredibly interesting. There's a hole. This is a paper from 30 years ago from I believe yeah 1987 from 30 years ago
There's still a huge amount of debate as to how snowflakes form
What is the underlying structure?
But what's important in this paper and in number of subsequent papers is that they've used a very simple?
relatively simple computer simulation to model just how
Snowflakes grow and running in the background. Here is a simulation called a diffusion limited aggregation simulation I didn't write it
It's actually written by one of the first-year students here again guy called Jimmy Mayer
I do a lecture just at the start of first semester when the first years arrive and
on chaos and various different aspects of chaos and one of those is related to fractals, which we are getting to slowly and
Jamie but I mentioned in the in the lecture well
if you really want to understand something coded and that's exactly what Jamie did and he's
Developed this simulation whereby what you have is lots and lots of little particles
They could be water molecules or ice particles from for example. They're moving around and
We have a really simple rule a really simple rule
Basically it moves around it follows a random walk which just means it's it's equal probability of going north south east
It's not right no
east-west and
So it follows that around it's also called a drunkards walk because you're just stumbling around all over the place
And if it hits another particle it sticks, and it doesn't disconnect
and then
What happens is that sticks and then the next particle moves around that sticks and that sticks and that sticks and gnostics and it becomes?
Very higgledy-piggledy, but what's interesting is it becomes very higgledy-piggledy, but with a very specific type of structure
It's random each time we run it, but the overall characteristics, and the statistics are the same time and time again
And it's called a fractal structure if you look at it you see this branching
And if you look for these patterns in nature you find them everywhere obviously ferns
trees
riverbeds a great deal of it stems from the work of
Mandelbrot and many of you will have heard of the Mandelbrot set the important thing in yours is why is it called a fractal so
Fractal is actually short
For fractional dimension so what does a fractional dimension mean so?
We got a line okay, you can move in that direction back and forth it's one-dimensional if you got an area square
It's two-dimensional if you've got a cube
Three-dimensional the problem is what about this it's not a close-packed structure
It's not a line, but then it's also not a closed enclosed volume or a closed area
It's somewhere in between the two and actually if we work it through
we find that it's it can be defined in terms of having a
fractional dimension somewhere between one day or 2d or in other cases between 2d and 3d
I'm looking at and saying to me
It looks like it's a 2d structure that so it's it's a 2d structure
But how do we actually define this dimension is a special type of dimension is a very good question so what we need to do
Is think about just how we break this structure down or just how we would form a structure like this or any other structure?
from
Building blocks, so let's take a line
And I've run out of room. Let me start again you may need to cut an awful lot of this out. You'll see
He'll ruler, thank you
Without wanting to cut to the punch line, but is this gonna be about how many blocks it takes actly so this is all about
scalability, and it's all about a
Concept which is basically self similarity, and that's very important when comes to fractals
So here we've got a line, and we can break that line up into well as many pieces as we like
But let's just keep three for simplicity so each one of those is exactly the same shape it's not only self-similar
It's identical apart from a scaling size, so how many pieces are we got there?
We've got three, and we've got one dimension similarly here now
We've got two dimensions, but we're going to divide this up into into a series of blocks
I've got 1 2 3 in that direction 1 2 3 in that direction, so we've got 9, and that's two dimensions here. We've got
27 and that's three dimensions now we can see a pattern here
Three this fairly straightforward is equal to 3 to the power of 1 9 is equal to 3 to the power of 2/3 or dimension
1 dimension 2 dimensions
27 is equal to 3 to the power of 3, so there's our dimension
Okay, so that's fine. Those are usual objects were very
familiar with those
How do we do what what what is that? How would we write down its dimensionality?
What's the what's the self similar bit so we could start without, but let's let's not want one thing
We could do is we could measure the ratio or the perimeter to the area? That's certainly one way to knit those objects are
Pretty well-defined and boring incredibly boring. We're gonna look at something called a Koch's snowflake
I'm not gonna try and
Measure this out because it'll just take too long so just bear with me. I'm gonna use a pencil in case I make a mistake
So you start off with an equilateral triangle, and then what you do is
you again divide this up into three and
You put another triangle in there?
With that's now your side length, so these are all equilateral triangles, and then you put another one over here
Just losing the lines yes
We're just losing the lines so largely because what we want is to have a continuous line
So now haven't got rid of those
There's our first generations snowflake
Then you do the same thing again divide this up into three put you in equilateral triangle in there
and then similarly here and here and
here and
here
Repeat repeat repeat repeat repeat and what you end up with is something?
That is pretty well drawn on the wiki page so of a triangle
Do that break it up break it up again break it up again break it up again. What's remarkable?
Is that now if you follow this process through?
and keep going this the the the line length here never converges so what you'll end up with is an
infinitely long line in a finite area
Which is a fairly compared to these very boring objects which are finite?
Finite finite finite both in in length and area here we have something which is
When you stand it out
And you kept going with our process you'd have an infinitely long line
In a finite area the important thing is that the perimeter length doesn't converge?
So it really is if you follow this to its natural limit, or your honda earned or whether something that's infinitely long
But it's in a finite area so looking at that. You're saying that it's constrained in an hour
Is that because it kind of like the angles work so that it just keeps working back on itself exactly, so it's it's confined
It's not diverging over that area. It's constrained with enough that within that area
Just due to exactly due to the geometry and I we could work this through if we just take this
so if we look at that relationship what we have is that the number of pieces n is equal to
the
Scale factor
S because what we've done is we've taken this and broken it down into three
To the power of the dimension so the number of pieces in this case
27 is the scale factor because we broke it down into three in all three dimensions
To the power of three for this one n would be equal to 27
This is going to be a long video short home geez s is going to be equal to three
That's our scale factor, and D is our dimensionality is going to be equal to three now
We're gonna have to do some maths or math depending on which side of the pond you you
livin
What we have here is n is equal to s to the power D
Now if we take logs some of you might remember logs what we'll find is log N
And one of the wonderful properties of logs is that raising to a power becomes a multiplication?
In Log land is equal to D times log s so I make sense you say log
Ya log at the number of blocks is equal to the dimension
times the log of the scale factor
Okay, they say it's going somewhere. Let's put that up here
Right so that's fine for these and when you work that through you find out that or let's actually go the next step
Just a 1 one more line of maths to work out what D is
Let's divide both sides by log s so log n divided by log s divided here by log S. We obviously
And what you find is if you work this process through and I?
Encourage you to do so then you find that you will get an integer value for the dimension
What happens if we do it to the snowflake so we'll start off with a line now?
We're going to divide it up into 3 and then remember we take our equilateral triangle
And if I can draw that correctly we put that equilateral triangle there
And then we get rid of that
But the important thing is we've taken a line, and we divide it in three
Didn't matter it. That's made that line longer in
It does and you're not sure well
You are jumping the gun
But you're jumping the gun in an exceptionally good way because that's exactly where I'm going so we're divided in three
But we've actually got four units now so one two three four remember. This is an equilateral triangle, so we've got it
We divided it in three, but we've got four units
Make sense so now our n is equal to four
But our s is equal to three not good. You know I like
So that means that D is equal to log
four
over log three
We've decided that what we're going to do in terms of how we're going to make this pattern is we're going to have a scale
Factor of three so each each individual line is a third of the original length
But we're just gonna set up our geometry so we need four of those lines
Okay, and if you work out then what the dimension is you'll find that that's something like 1.2. It's not an integer
It's a fractional dimension, so that's fractals
That's where it comes from it's it's we probably had to do too much maths, but we've done a little bit
but as you can see the beauty of maths the beauty and power of math is you get so much out of it so if
We went then to the next level we would obviously put a triangle in the middle of here
But we're doing the same process again and would that increase it
No, so it's the same process time and time again
So you only have to do it at this level because you're asking yourself at each level and the important thing is itself similar
So you can you can look at it in a growth scale and then you can zoom in and zoom in?
overall you're gonna see the same structure, so now we've connected the
snowflake
Wonderful festive snowflake to the mathematics and a computing
Let's explore that in a little bit more detail because when you look for these fractal things. They're right across nature in fact a
Physicist what we tend to look for is very ordered, and I'm a physicist
I'm sort of interloping here in computerphile, but I'm definitely a physicist
We tend to look for very ordered things very structured things crystals
We spend so much of our life thinking about crystals, and how atoms are incredibly well-ordered etc
But in fact if you look across the answer that's not what it's like at all
We you know those incredibly crystalline structures?
You know were not crystalline if we were crystalline would be incredibly boring if we were crystalline
Then you wouldn't have the randomness that you need for evolution you wouldn't have the randomness that you need for information transfer, etc so
Crystalline and very ordered structures are the exception rather than the rule which makes these type of structures
fascinating so fractals can contain more and more and more
I'm trying not to use the word data
but I'm going to use the word data data in one same contained area is this something we can use for memory so that's a
Fascinating question, thank you for that sure that brings me to this wonderful structure some of you might be familiar with this
It's called the Mandelbrot set I hope some of you from any of that if you're not familiar with the Mandelbrot set just stop listening
To me drone on go and look it up go and spend a few hours
So I'm not gonna go into the details of the algorithm
Wiki is actually again. Pretty good in terms of the Mandelbrot set and you if you
Google, Mandelbrot set you will find beautiful image upon beautiful image upon beautiful image
This is what it looks like and it's actually a process that happens on the complex plane involving imaginary numbers
But we don't need all that detail
Important thing is that you have a grid and in each point in that grid you do a particular algorithm
It's a particular. You can even see you set it up in a while loop. You keep that running and you
basically let that run until it reaches a certain limit and
What you find is when you do that process you get this incredible
Structure you get all this complexity coming out of an algorithm
Which involves nothing more than squaring a number and an addition
That's all it involves and yet you get all this incredible complex details so complexity from something very straightforward
That would be good enough. You look at this, and it's you know. It's it's incredible
You can see the sort of almost snowflake dendritic structure again the branching
It's a mathematical landscape, and then if you zoom in to this particular region
I've just taken out at random you start to see this little bit more like the snowflake structure by the way
This is a piece of code. I wrote using something called LabVIEW a number of years ago in fact
I rolled it so long ago
I couldn't find the original code
And it also gives you an idea of just how disorganized I am but
We zoom in again and looked snowflakes everywhere we see the same type of fractal structure, and we can keep going
And we can keep going and we can keep going on we can keep going forever
Forever it never stops as long as you've got enough computing power
You can do this till the end of the end of time, and it would never stop yet. You can code it in five lines
If you're a better program than me probably three lines
It's it's remarkable so when you think about that in terms of information if we were to take every
Individual pixel here and try and cold it and store it we need just no vast amounts of memory
But we can capture that in five lines or less
It's it's mind-blowing when you think about so finally how does that all connect back to the brain?
Which is where we came in back in physics world in March
You can see coding and computing it were finally starting to get
Computer scientists and physicists to talk together a heck of a lot more than they used to do
There's a great article in here a number of great articles, but there's some Jessamyn fairfield
He used to work in john Bolin's group in Trinity College in Dublin is now in Galway see the articles called smarter machines
And she talks about the work that she was involved in in in Bolin's group and dublin of work - she drove
So usually when we think about nano electronics when we think about trying to get faster capacities and more
computing power we think about being very
regimented and very controlled in terms of how we we have ordered structure in the surface and we'll use lithography and
Billion-dollar plants to really do this very very fine machining
What they do is they sort of chuck a load of nano wires so they take a solution not that different from this?
Put it on a surface. Let it dry and
You get a higgledy-piggledy net or mesh of wires all connecting against each other and again. It's an open structure
it's not an incredibly close packed lots and lots of different connections that can form and
That gives rise doing really
fascinating
Properties including the ability for the network to rewire itself
And that's something our brain does our brain is incredibly plastic in terms of forming connections
And it also has a multitude of connections that branch off much like the sort of fractal structures
We've been looking like this the question of whether the brain is fractal is again something
That's been debated at length time and time again
but it certainly has that large range of different connections that we don't have in the type of
technology silicon technology that underpins
We have so much of our world our brains are sort of more along these lines
and they call this neuromorphic a neuromorphic device because it's mimicking the type of or
Hoping to mimic the type of process that happens in our brains look into that picture and the way you've just described it
They're creating wires in some sense, but without any purpose not any purpose, but they're just a bunch of wires
And they don't know what they do precisely yes, so instead of is it's like my wiring curbs, which is full of old faux
No leads and things and if I just put some power in it. Hopefully it might start thinking
Perhaps I wouldn't be that extreme if your way when corporate become sentient you're on the way to a Nobel Prize
Let's put it that way just keep quiet about it
But don't let it get to sentient that wouldn't be good
This is like a
ground-up way of
Exactly using something rather than being an architect and saying this is where the foundations will be here's what I've got
I will work with that
That's exactly it so instead of being constrained by I need to put this here and this here
And I need to have this interconnect here
And I've got to worry about leakage and I've got a how will that fit with the particular
Blueprint, I have let's throw away the blueprint just throw some stuff down and let's say well
What function does it give me and if it doesn't give me a function well let's move on to the next one throw some more
stuff down and
That's a refreshing way to think it's not an engineering where to think it's more by a biological way to think it's hard to understand
That this would ever work at all it does some remarkable things in terms of they can train
Not just this group or a number of groups across the world you can train these things to to recognize certain pulse
Sequences for example just in terms of what they're being fed in terms of signals, so it's yeah
it's it's very much in its infancy in fact as
Although it's very much in his infancy. There's a massive project which is created and
Generated a huge amount of controversy called the human brain project which is an eu-funded
Projects over 1 billion euros we have interviewed professor Stephen Ferber the human brain project is wonderful, so let's put a link down there
yeah, and
Using a million ARM chips it was the thinking then I don't know where that's gone. We haven't yeah
Yeah, we were to check them, but I know they were thinking about a range of different strategies and possibilities
And I think as far as I understand that one of those was a little bit more along the lines of this neuromorphic
Approach I could be wrong. I'm sure I would be corrected at length and
Repeatedly in the comments section if I am wrong, and I look forward to that very much
This is a bit Ong. Let's not critique me too much, and so yeah be very different, ooh
The originals and the important thing is that we don't know what went into here, right we know G
But we don't know a and we can't find the motion which is comparable to the type of effects
We have to consider when we're thinking about black holes